foreign
Texas is where we go next Gavin is there
Gavin how can we help
thanks for taking my call so I'm on baby
step number two and I was just curious
my last piece of debt is my Tesla I have
nineteen thousand dollars left on it but
the part I'm torn on is I don't want to
sell it because I have free charging
where I'm at and with the little to no
maintenance that the car provides it's
actually very comparable to the cash
flow if I had a ten thousand dollar gas
car for example so I was wondering what
Dave and you guys would recommend should
I sell the car pay off my last piece of
debt today or should I keep the Tesla at
the 2.49 interest rate and just try to
pay it down as fast as possible
all right so what's your income
so I'm a real estate agent and my income
varies quite a bit the last year to date
I made a hundred thousand dollars
already some months will be 25 to 30
grand and other months could be as
little as two to three grand so it's
very variable okay but on average you're
saying in a year you're going to make
six figures
yes sir okay and what is a Tesla worth
so the Tesla on Kelley Blue Book today
says a private party would pay forty
thousand dollars so I have about twenty
one thousand dollars in equity in it so
I could easily sell it and buy a 10 or
15 000 gas car
I also have free charging where I
currently live and I save about six to
seven hundred dollars a month not paying
for gas and the car payment's 580 and
has three years left you're spending 700
on gas a month if you had a gas car
yeah that's what the app says wow I
don't know if I trust the app and this
is coming from a Tesla owner but uh
laying out the numbers I don't do
anything for the gas savings uh the
numbers here uh don't shock me so you
make over 100k the car is worth 40K
that's reasonable you're making good
money in real estate why not just
aggressively pay it off
that's what I'm planning on I was just a
little torn because if I sold it today I
could be debt free today and I could
probably pay it off in the next three to
six months is my goal
um also with the interest rates
increasing in business having slowed
down considerably I don't know if I'm
going to be making 100K the next year it
just kind of depends on how things work
out since it's very commission based so
you're in baby step two how much money
do you have in the bank right now
I don't have that much I have a couple
Grand in the savings and my plan was to
you know either start increasing that
savings to the three to six months or be
aggressively paying off the car but I
was a little bit torn since like I said
I could pay it off today and just be
done with it
yeah I mean you love the Tesla I'm
guessing right
of course yeah I slept on the decision
for about three years before I bought it
I did tons of homework I understand it
from the ground up I work with a lot of
Tesla clients I've been to the Tesla
Rodeo when they opened up the factory
here so I'm very ingrained
yeah I don't I think you just pay it off
aggressively the next 20 grand
commission check you get be done with it
and don't go I'll put three grand on it
because I really want to build no now is
the time to pay off debt I would take
everything except a thousand dollars
throw it at the car this is time to uh
to really get aggressive at this thing
and the next few commission checks you
get be done with it and then save your
three to six months of expenses but no
no nothing's pointing to you got to go
sell the car
okay but it's not for the gas savings I
think that's a great perk but I'm doing
it because it's not a huge part of your
world and you can pay it off quickly if
you're gonna tell me it's going to take
me take me three years four years to pay
this thing off with my income and it's a
50 000 Tesla and I make 40. I go sell it
today you're broke but that's not the
situation here
okay that makes total sense thank you
yeah and I just one little Challenge on
the work side of things I understand the
real estate market is in some way
slowing down there's no question about
that but I wouldn't accept that you know
if I was in a situation like that I
wouldn't go okay well the market is what
the market is I would be planning uh I
would be looking at okay what can I do
what kind of pipeline do I need to have
in order to keep up the pace that I've
kept up in the past I wouldn't accept
that well the market is what the market
is I you can still sell houses in this
market oh absolutely
um and so I just heard a tinge of that
and I want to challenge a pessimism yeah
with interest rates going up and well
it's cooling off I would call it excuses
oh it's not a word but I just made it a
word it's like well you know you can't
pay it off as fast as I like because no
to your point pay the thing off yeah and
if real estate slows down go get a side
gig yeah you can always make money yeah
there you go by the way that app and the
700 on come on I don't buy it that's a
little outrageous what app was that the
Tesla app well of course they're saying
that that's what I was telling him
yeah elon's no idiot he's he's juicing
the numbers because he doesn't want you
to get rid of him out to Gavin's point I
get free charging at work as well Ken so
there's a sweet perk thanks Dave and I
park right next to Dave just to make him
angry as he drives in and his Raptor
yeah it's a lot of fun yeah well this
car could eat mine for breakfast it
would be like a snack to his Raptor but
it's fun I hope one day he accidentally
just drives over your car you know what
I mean turn it into the spot and he
doesn't realize and he cut it too close
and he just goes oh it's George's Tesla
I tell you this it would either be
accidental or very intentional oh I
think it would be accidental at first
but then he'd roll it off as intentional
he's like well it is what it is it is
what it is you go George here's a here's
a plug thank you here's a check and a
plug go get yourself another electric
toy well Rachel Park's next to me and so
for his own daughter to drive that thing
that really bothers too much I don't
want to live my life trying to find the
next freaking Outlet all right I have
too much stress in my own house
at the camel house my wife drives one so
road trips we take the SUV it's no big
deal